.
WE DON'T HAVE HAMILTON WITH
US BUT WE HAVE FORMER UTAH
CONGRESSMAN, FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR JASON CHAFFETZ.
THE BORDER WAS AN ISSUE
BEFORE YOU GOT TO CONGRESS,
WHILE YOU WERE IN CONGRESS
AND STILL AN ISSUE.
ARE ANY OF US GOING TO LIVE
LONG ENOUGH TO SEE THE
BORDER RESOLVED?
>> WELL, THEY SHOULD.
IT HAS BEEN A LACK OF
POLITICAL WILL.
THE LAWS ARE ON THE BOOK,
BUILD A BORDER WALL TO DENY
PEOPLE TO JUST SIMPLY WALK
ACROSS THE BORDER.
IT HAS BEEN A LACK OF
POLITICAL WILL.
BIDEN-HARRIS ADMINISTRATION
AND OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
HAVE DONE EVERYTHING THEY
CAN.
INVITING PEOPLE TO COME
HERE.
AND WITH THE EXPIRATION OF
TITLE 42, A JUDGE PUT THAT
ORDER IN PLACE, I THINK
THERE ARE STILL TENS OR
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE THAT WILL POUR ACROSS
AT 18,000 PEOPLE A DAY.
TRYING TO COME IN TO THE
COUNTRY IN ADDITION TO
MILLIONS THAT HAVE ALREADY
PLOWED ACROSS THE BORDERS.
>> NOT JUST THE PANDEMIC,
THIS IS A NATIONAL SECURITY
ISSUE, A LAW ENFORCEMENT
ISSUE.
DO YOU THINK THAT THE
PANDEMIC IS STILL A
SUFFICIENT WHILE DANGER TO
HEALTH DANGER TO CONTINUE
TRIGGERING TITLE 42.
OR SHOULD THEY JUST SAY, YOU
ARE NOT COMING TO THE
COUNTRY FOR OTHER REASONS?
>> IT IS HUMAN TRAFFICKING,
I TALKED WITH BORDER AGENTS
WHO BELIEVE UPWARDS OF 90%
OF WOMEN TRAFFICKED ACROSS
THE BORDERER RAPED ON THE
WAY.
IT SAY DRUG PROBLEM.
THE PROBLEM WITH FENTANYL.
THE TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
AMERICANS THAT HAVE LOST
THEIR LIVES.
HUMAN TRAFFICKING, YOU THINK
THAT WOULD BE ENOUGH.
WOULD THINK THAT DRUGS WOULD
BE ENOUGH, THE CARTELS ARE
ESSENTIALLY RUNS THE BORDER,
I KNOW THAT SECRETARY
MAJORCAS SAID HE WITH
OPERATIONAL CONTROL WHOOMP
WE DO NOT, IT IS BORDER
PATROL, TALK TO BORDER
PATROL, NOT AN AGENT
OUT THERE WHO THINKS WE HAVE
CONTROL, ALLOW THE MIN AND
WOMEN TO DO THEIR JOB, PUSH
THE PEOPLE BACK AND GET BACK
TO THE PEOPLE, WE'RE FAILING
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE TRYING
TO DO IT LEGALLY AND
LAWFULLY, THOSE ARE THE
PEOPLE WE'RE FAILING.
TREY: ALL RIGHT, ON THAT
POINT, I HAVE THIS VAGUE
RECOLLECTION WHEN WE WERE
THERE TOGETHER, YOU SPENT A
LOT OF TIME LOOKING AT FRAUD
IN REFUGEE AND ASYLUM
PROGRAMS.
DO I RECALL THAT RIGHT?
WHAT DID YOU FIND WHAT YOU
LOOKED FOR EVIDENCE OF FRAUD
IN THE TWO PROGRAMS?
>> I WAS ON IMMIGRATION
SUBCOMMITTEE, ON JUDICIARY
WE LOOKED AT ASYLUM,
STARTING WITH OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION, IT USED TO
BE YOU HAD TO COME FROM
SOUTH SUDAN WHERE THERE IS
REAL CONFLICT.
BUT OBAMA CHANGED IT TO HEY
YOUR BOYFRIEND IS BEATING
YOU UP THAT IS GOOD, AND
CLIMATE CHANGE THAT IS
ENOUGH, IT TURNED INTO A
MASSIVE ABUSE.
WE SEE STREAMS OF PEOPLE
COMING ACROSS, WITH NOTES IN
THEIR POCKETS, THEY GET IT
ODD AND READ IT, AND PEOPLE
OF UNITED STATES SAY, YOU
CAN BE HERE, YOU HAVE TO GO
THROUGH YOUR ASYLUM CLAIM,
YOU WILL DO THAT 12 YEARS
FROM NOW.
WHEN I WAS LOOKING AT IT
THERE WERE ONLY 3
ADMINISTRATIVE JUDGES FOR
IMMIGRATION IN THE STATE OF
ARIZONA, THREE, IT WAS A
JOKE, IT WAS NEVER MENT TO
HAVE THE AJUDICATION PROCESS
WORK.
TREY: IF YOU UTTER THE RIGHT
ALLEGATIONS WITH RESPECT TO
ASEE LO TO ASYLUM, YOU
WILL REMAIN IN THIS COUNTRY
UNTIL YOUR COURT HEARING,
AND MAY OR MAY NOT GO
LOOKING FOR YOU.
>> YOU SAY, WELL THE JUDGE
GAVE ME A DATE, IT IS YEARS
IN ADVANCE, BUT I HAVE TO
WORK AND GO TO SCHOOL AND
GET MEDICINE.
ALL OF WHICH AMERICAN PEOPLE
PAY FOR, YOU GO BACK TO THE
COURT, AND SUDDENLY YOU HAVE
PAPERS, AND YOU CAN GO AND
COMPETE AGAINST THE
AMERICANS FOR AMERICAN JOBS.
TREY: JAS